Sean, I got to tell you something. Okay. Really important. Okay. We're recording right now. Yes, yes, yes. The show is starting. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
西恩，我得跟你说个事。好吧。真的非常重要。好吧。我们现在正在录音。对，对，对。节目开始了。对，对，对。
Well, it hasn't started. And this is the show. Yeah, but it hasn't technically started. No, but this is, no, of course it started because it's rolling. I know, but this isn't the show. This is the part before the show. Of course it is. No, this is the show.
嗯，还没开始。这就是节目。对，但严格来说还没开始。不，但这，不，当然开始了，因为已经在录了。我知道，但这还不是节目。这是节目开始前的那部分。当然是。不，这就是节目。
No. Sean, stop waiting for your life to start, man. You're in it. This is Smartless. Smart Less Smart Less
不。西恩，别再等待你的生活开始了，老兄。你就在其中。这就是 Smartless。Smart Less Smart Less
Hey you know what I did last night I didn't even tell you guys I went to the John Williams concert at the Hollywood Bowl Oh, no kidding now I know why you didn't tell us Yeah Come on John Williams
嘿，你知道我昨晚做了什么吗？我都没告诉你们，我去了好莱坞露天剧场看约翰·威廉姆斯的音乐会。哦，不是吧，现在我知道你为什么不告诉我了。对。拜托，那是约翰·威廉姆斯。
Let me tell you something Are you still up? It sounds like a rager It was amazing Here's this guy John Williams Amazing Conductor He's 89 years I know. We're kidding.
我跟你说个事。你还没睡吗？听起来像个狂欢。太棒了。这就是约翰·威廉姆斯，了不起的指挥家。他89岁了。我知道。我们在开玩笑。
Conducting all of the better. All of the songs we love. E.T., Raiders of Lost Dark, Star Wars, all in this new stuff. It was incredible. I wanted to go to that. Now, did he do a lot of the conducting? No.
指挥着所有更好的。所有我们喜爱的歌曲。《E.T.》、《夺宝奇兵》、《星球大战》，还有所有这些新作品。太棒了。我也想去那场。那么，他指挥了很多吗？没有。
He did the second half. Yeah, the first half was David Newman. Yeah? It was also great. But it was amazing. I know. I'm nerded out. The Mozart night that you sent me,
他指挥了下半场。对，上半场是大卫·纽曼。是吗？也很棒。但真的很棒。我知道。我这个狂热迷。你发给我的莫扎特之夜，
I'm so bummed. I'm not here for. Yeah, I said, Jay, let's go see Mozart. Yeah, Sean and I are going to have a classical music date. Under the Stars. Jason originally you said yes you thought because you thought it was the thing was cut in hat
我太遗憾了。我没能去。对，我说，杰伊，我们去看莫扎特吧。对，西恩和我准备来一次古典音乐约会。繁星之下。杰森，你最初说好是因为你以为那是……因为你以为那是切成
you thought it was mozzarella and you were like yes I'm in and then it turned out it was Mozart and you're like not as interesting he's like fried mozzarella granddad joke you've done guys today's guest
你以为那是马苏里拉奶酪，当时你还说，好啊算我一个，结果发现是莫扎特，然后你就觉得没那么有趣了，就像炸马苏里拉奶酪一样，老头子的笑话，你们今天聊的……今天的嘉宾
oh get down to business Sean she's an amazing woman I love her she's a friend of all of ours and boy does she make me laugh she's been a stand-up comedian basically her whole life less red Sean
哦，言归正传吧，西恩。她是个了不起的女人，我爱她。她是咱们所有人的朋友，天哪，她太能逗人笑了。她基本上当了一辈子的单口喜剧演员。红头发少一点，西恩。
less red try to find the world I don't know how to to do it without reading. And boy, do I love her. She is our... God. I do love her. She's...
红头发少一点。试着找那个词，我不知道怎么不用读的。天哪，我是真爱她。她是我们的……天哪。我是真爱她。她是……
She means how much it was. She's done everything. She's in specials, acting gigs, hosting, she does everything. Here's what I love. She's opinionated. She's fearless. She's hilarious.
她是想说这有多了不起。她什么都做过。她有专场演出、表演通告、当主持，她什么都做。这就是我喜欢的地方。她很有主见。她无所畏惧。她滑稽搞笑。
She's gorgeous. And gay men can't get enough of her. Really? It's my friend and our friend, Chelsea Handler. Chelsea! Oh, my God. Oh, yeah. Chelsea.
她美艳动人。而且同性恋男士对她爱不释手。真的吗？她就是我的朋友，也是我们的朋友，切尔西·汉德勒。切尔西！哦，天哪。哦，对，切尔西。
Oh, hi, white guys in one room. That's right. We're going to get some more to join us later. Look at you. Where are you, Chelsea? Are you at home? I am in my office. No, I'm in Las Vegas, actually.
哦，嗨，一屋子的白人男士。没错。我们待会儿还会让其他人加入。看看你。你在哪儿，切尔西？你在家吗？我在我的办公室。不，其实我在拉斯维加斯。
I had a show here last night. Because you're on tour. I'm on tour, so yeah. What's the name of the tour again? The unvaccinated, what? No, it's called vaccinated and horny, Sean. We came up with that together. Is it truly?
我昨晚在这里有一场演出。因为你在巡演。我在巡演，所以对。巡演叫什么来着？接种过疫苗的，什么？不，叫“接种过疫苗且饥渴难耐”，西恩。这是我们一起想出来的。真的吗？
So I'd appreciate a little respect. Yes. That's right. We came up with it together. and ready to rumble. Is there a subtitle? Says everybody should get a little prick? No, it's just the tip is the subtitle.
所以我希望能得到一点尊重。对。没错。这就是我们一起想出来的。蓄势待发。有副标题吗？是不是说每个人都该挨一针？不，副标题就是“只是先端一下”。
But thank you for your, thank you. I love to spitball with you guys. Yeah, let's workshop it. After we already named the tour. So yes, let's keep doing that. Chelsea, thanks for joining us. And thank you for bringing up with Jason's punch-ups that he's obviously trying to give you.
不过谢谢你的，谢谢。我喜欢和你们一起即兴创作。对，我们来润色一下吧。在我们已经给巡演起好名字之后。所以是的，我们继续那样做吧。切尔西，谢谢你加入我们。也谢谢你忍受杰森那些显然是想给你的建议。
I love Jason's punch-ups. Always. They're cheap. So are you staying in Vegas for a while? or is it just one of the stops there? No, I just had a stop here. I'm headed to, I'm just on tour. So it's, you know, different cities every day.
我喜欢杰森的建议。总是这样。很廉价。那你会在拉斯维加斯待上一阵子吗？还是这只是其中一站？不，我刚在这里停一站。我要去，我只是在巡演。所以，你知道，每天都是不同的城市。
Next, just all over the country. All the places you want to go, Cincinnati, Grand Rapids, Michigan, places like that. Florida, Jacksonville. Do you like constantly moving and touring? Like, does it get, or do you miss home base and being still? It's like a shark. She can't stop. Yeah, no, I'm over.
接下来，就是全国各地。所有你想去的地方，辛辛那提、密歇根州的大急流城，诸如此类的地方。佛罗里达州，杰克逊维尔。你喜欢不断地搬迁和巡演吗？这会让你感到……还是你会想念大本营和安静的生活？她就像一条鲨鱼。她停不下来。对，不，我受够了。
I like to, I don't like to sit still for very long. Sean came with me on tour once last year, two years ago, was it? Yeah, it was so fun. Yeah, you complained the entire time. I did. Tell us. Yeah, let's hear it.
我喜欢，我不喜欢坐定太久。去年西恩跟我去过一次巡演，两年前，是吗？对，太有趣了。对，你一路上都在抱怨。我确实抱怨了。告诉我们。对，让我们听听。
Oh, it was such a pain in the ass. Was he like an opening act or was he choreographer or what was he going on the tour? No, no, this is a, no, no, I read Chelsea's book, Life will be the death of me, mostly because Chelsea called me and asked me to go on tour with her and chat about it and she said, but she said, you actually have to read the book. Oh, boy. So I read the book. So you had to learn how to read.
哦，那真是太麻烦了。他是作为暖场嘉宾去的，还是编舞，还是他去巡演干嘛的？不，不，这是一个，不，不，我读了切尔西的书《生活将是我的死因》，主要是因为切尔西打电话让我跟她一起去巡演并聊聊这本书，她说，但她说，你必须真的把书读完。哦，天哪。所以我读了书。所以你得学会认字。
So you had to learn how to read. Then you had to get the book. Up to bottom. But I laughed out loud. I was, you know what I was when I read that book? I was like enlightened. Like you taught me things I brought up with you on the tour. It was, I was filled with insight about who you are and why you are, all those things.
所以你得学会认字。然后你还得拿到书。从头看到尾。但我读得哈哈大笑。你知道我读那本书的时候是什么状态吗？我简直像开悟了一样。就像你教了我一些我在巡演中向你提起过的事情。那里面，我充满了对你是谁、你为什么会成为现在的你这些事情的深刻理解。
And in the book, you know, one of the things to talk about your, in that book was your brother passed away when you're like nine and he was older than you. And obviously, you know, I want to ask you this, you know, something like that never leaves you and has a tremendous impact on a child of that age. But for those of us who haven't suffered, like, a loss like that as a child, how did that inform you going further, like through your teenage years and adulthood? And does that still inform you in certain ways? Well, I think, you know, when it happens, you're a nine-year-old person, so you can't even really articulate what's happening or digest it in any real way. It just feels like abandonment or rejection.
而在书中，你知道，其中一件事是谈到你的，在那本书里谈到你的哥哥在大约九岁的时候去世了，他比你大。显然，你知道，我想问你这个，你知道，那样的事情永远不会离开你，并且会对那个年龄的孩子产生巨大的影响。但对于我们这些在童年没有遭受过这种损失的人来说，这件事是如何影响你未来的，比如通过你的青少年时期和成年期？在某些方面，它至今仍在影响着你吗？嗯，我想，你知道，当事情发生时，你是一个九岁的人，所以你甚至无法真正清晰地表达发生了什么，或者以任何真正的方式去消化它。它感觉就像被抛弃或拒绝。
So you kind of pack it away and then just distract yourself for the next 35 years. Yeah, yeah. And until it fucking comes and taps you on the shoulder and then you have to address it with a professional. Like once your anger stops working for you in that way and you become too angry, which is what happened to me, then you sit down with somebody and you're like, you pay somebody to tell you what the fuck is wrong with you, right?
所以你把它打包收好，然后在接下来的35年里只是分散自己的注意力。对，对。直到它他妈的来敲你的肩膀，然后你必须和一个专业人士来处理这件事。就像一旦你的愤怒不再为你发挥那种作用，你变得太愤怒了——这也是发生在我身上的事——然后你坐下来和某人面谈，你付钱给某人来告诉你他妈的你有什么毛病，对吧？
That's a transaction I like therapy. You're paying someone to tell you, you know, why you're acting like such a cunt. So it was a process of just understanding that many of my behaviors were a reaction to what happened to me as a little girl and the inability to ever really healthily deal with that and digest it kind of turns you into maybe somebody that you're not
我喜欢这种交易，我喜欢治疗。你付钱让人家告诉你，你知道，你为什么表现得像个这么混账的碧池。所以这个过程仅仅是去理解我的许多行为其实是我小时候发生的事情的一种反应，而无法真正健康地处理和消化那件事，会把你变成一个可能不是你自己的人，
or maybe it is your personality, but it makes you kind of assess yourself. You want to, it's the gift of self-awareness. You want to reflect and go, oh, wait, is this why I'm so impulsive? Is this why I don't want to be, you know, this is why I love being single and I don't have to depend on anybody, you know, all of that stuff.
或者也许这就是你的个性，但它会让你开始评估自己。你想去，这就是自我觉察的礼物。你想反思并心想，哦，等等，这就是为什么我这么冲动吗？这就是为什么我不想成为，你知道，这就是为什么我喜欢单身而且我不需要依赖任何人，你知道，所有这些事情。
All that stuff, yeah. So, yeah. Well, I think it's amazing, though, because, yeah, all that therapy. I'm sorry. Did you want to interrupt me again, Sean? For me, for sake. So sorry. You know, I live for it.
所有这些事情，对。所以，对。嗯，我觉得这很了不起，因为，是的，所有的那些心理治疗。对不起。你又想打断我吗，西恩？为了我，看在老天的份上。非常抱歉。你知道，我为它而活。
I live for you. Okay, so keep going, sorry. But I want to, well, we were talking about that because, so Sean came to Chicago, the Chicago Theater, right? Yeah. We performed at, or you interviewed me at, and the whole time he was just, like, you know, complaining about the flight out, and he had to bring Scotty, of course, which is obviously an added bonus.
我为你而活。好吧，所以继续说，抱歉。但我想，嗯，我们当时在谈论这个，因为，所以西恩去了芝加哥，芝加哥剧院，对吧？对。我们在那里演出，或者你采访了我，而他一整路上都在，你知道，就像抱怨去那里的航班，当然他还不得不带上斯科蒂，这显然是一个额外的福利。
Anytime you have to deal with Sean, it's better to have Scotty around. Amen. Because it's like his man. This is true. And we had a great conversation on stage, right? Yeah, it was so fun. Yeah, we had a great time. And then you just kept asking me how much I was going to reimburse you for the trip.
任何时候只要你得应付西恩，身边有个斯科蒂会更好。阿门。因为这就好像是他的男伴。确实如此。我们在舞台上进行了一次很棒的对话，对吧？对，太有趣了。对，我们度过了一段美好的时光。然后你就不停地问我这次旅行你要报销我多少钱。
Right. Yeah. By the way, still waiting. How much you make and how much you got when you sold your house? Yeah, he loves to talk about money. I love it. I love it. It's crazy.
对。顺便说一句，还在等。你赚了多少钱，卖了房子拿到多少钱？对，他最喜欢谈论钱。我喜欢。我喜欢。太疯狂了。
Money makes the world go around. I like to know how it makes the world. Speaking of money, when you're in Vegas, do you like the tables? Do you like the slots? so you got a loose slot that you prefer? Yeah, I play blackjack a lot. Although Will and I were in Vegas once and we played craps.
钱让世界转动。我喜欢了解它是如何让世界运转的。说到钱，你在拉斯维加斯时，你喜欢赌桌吗？你喜欢老虎机吗？你有没有比较偏爱的好出奖的老虎机？对，我经常玩二十一点。不过威尔和我以前在拉斯维加斯的时候，我们玩过掷骰子。
I had never played craps before. And that was fun because Will knew how to play craps and your other friend. What was your friend's name, Will? Beast, Mark Foreman. Beast, yes. Beast. Yeah. You lent him money.
我以前从未玩过掷骰子。那挺好玩的，因为威尔懂怎么玩掷骰子，还有你的另一个朋友。你那个朋友叫什么名字来着，威尔？野兽，马克·福尔曼。野兽，对。野兽。对。你借给他钱。
In fact, he was like, he worked for me at the time, and he still does, works with me. But now, but he had no money. And he was like, no, I don't want to. And you're like, take some money. Chelsea just grab, push some of her chips over. to him like, here, beast, just take this. And he was like, oh, my God, what the hell?
事实上，他当时，他那时为我工作，现在也还在为我工作，跟我一起。但现在，但他当时没有钱。然后他就像是，不，我不要。而你却说，拿去一些钱。切尔西直接抓起、推了一些她的筹码过去给他，就像是，给你，野兽，拿去吧。然后他当时就想，哦，天哪，搞什么鬼？
Now, Chelsea, when we worked on tour two, I was, I'm just fascinated with your family and your upbringing because there's some crossover in the mind, too, about how kind of just screwed up it was. But I remember you telling me that your mom, no, no, wait, your dad was Jewish and your mom was Mormon, right? My mom was Mormon and my dad is Jewish, yeah. So what, so what religion was, was. was forced upon you, if any, growing up.
切尔西，当我们一起巡演时，我，我只是对你的家庭和你的成长经历着迷，因为在思想上也有一些交集，关于它是怎么个一团糟法。但我记得你告诉我，你妈妈，不，不，等等，你爸爸是犹太人，你妈妈是摩门教徒，对吧？我妈妈是摩门教徒，我爸爸是犹太人，对。那么，那么，什么宗教，被强加在，如果你小时候有的话。
And did you... Well, not fucking Mormon, because we all told my mom to take a long walk off of a long pier. And we didn't take that seriously. Once I realized, we broke it down. My dad was the dominating person in that marriage. And my mom was German.
然后你……嗯，才不是他妈的摩门教，因为我们所有人都叫我妈妈去长长的码头上散步（滚蛋）。我们才不把那当回事。等我意识到之后，我们分析了一下。我爸爸是那段婚姻中占据支配地位的人。而我妈妈是德国人。
So she came over after the war. So we weren't about to take anything seriously that she said. You know what I mean? He was Jewish, and she was going to just shut up about being German for a long time until things blew over from World War II.
所以她在战后搬了过来。所以我们才不会把她说的任何话当真。你知道我的意思吗？他是犹太人，而她打算对自己的德国背景闭口不谈很久，直到二战的事情风头过去。
So we... Did she marry him out of guilt? What happened? I think maybe that had some... They had quite a love affair, my parents. He met her in a ski store. He was buying ski socks. Sure.
所以我们……她是出于内疚才嫁给他的吗？发生了什么？我想也许那有一点……我父母曾有过一段相当轰烈的爱情。他在一家滑雪店遇到她。他在买滑雪袜。当然。
And he saw her legs. Just the socks. No way. Yeah, just the socks. He didn't ski either. He just went in there to buy a size 12 pair of socks or something like that, you know? Anyway, they had a love affair. My mother agreed to raise all her children Jewish.
然后他看到了她的腿。只看到了袜子。不会吧。对，只看到袜子。他也不会滑雪。他只是走进去买一双12码的袜子之类的东西，你知道的？不管怎样，他们谈了一场恋爱。我母亲同意把她所有的孩子都抚养为犹太人。
So I thought my mom was Jewish until my brother. died and then it was a big thing because, you know, in Judaism, Jews all have to be buried in a Jewish cemetery together. So when they had to buy my, like a plot of graves, when my brother died and they wanted to buy one for both of my parents. And I remember our rabbi was at our house and he's like, Rita, my mother, isn't Jewish. She can't be buried in a Jewish cemetery. And I was like, that was the first I had heard of it. And I was like, what do you mean? Mom's not Jewish? What's Mom? And, you know, I was nine. So nobody really took my feelings seriously or into account. They just thought she doesn't really understand what's going on. And then when my mom
所以我一直以为我妈妈是犹太人，直到我哥哥去世，然后这就成了一件大事，因为，你知道，在犹太教中，犹太人都必须一起埋葬在犹太人公墓里。所以当他们不得不为我买，就像一块墓地时，在我哥哥去世的时候，他们想为我父母两人各买一块。我记得我们的拉比在我们的家里，他说，丽塔，我的母亲，不是犹太人。她不能埋在犹太人公墓里。然后我就想，那是我第一次听到这种事，我就想，你是什么意思？妈妈不是犹太人？妈妈是什么？而且，你知道，我当时九岁。所以没有人真正把我的感受当回事，也没有人把我的感受考虑在内。他们只是觉得她并不真正理解发生了什么。然后当我妈妈
did pass away, she never converted to Judaism. She was Mormon. Like she wore the undergarments. She had missionaries at her house all the time. And so when she did pass away, my dad was like, listen, we have to have, you know, we're having a Jewish funeral for your mother so that she can be buried next to your brother. And we're like, dad, this is such bullshit. Like all of her Mormon friends are coming to the funeral. Like they're all at our house. we can't do that. He's like, don't make eye contact with any of those people, okay?
去世时，她从未皈依犹太教。她是摩门教徒。就像她穿着那种内衣。她家里随时都有传教士。所以当她真的去世时，我爸爸就说，听着，我们必须举行，你知道的，我们为你母亲举办一场犹太葬礼，这样她就能和你哥哥埋在一起。而我们就说，爸爸，这太扯淡了。就像她所有的摩门教朋友都要来参加葬礼。就像他们都在我们家一样，我们不能这么做。他说，不要和那些人有任何眼神接触，好吗？
We just have to get through the funeral and get her in the ground. And I was like, my family was so fucked up. We couldn't even get funerals, right? Oh, my God, wow. What a crazy world. Imagine, here's somebody, she's your mom, she's your dad's wife.
我们只需要度过葬礼，把她埋进土里就行了。然后我就想，我的家里人太操蛋了。我们连葬礼都搞不定吗？哦，天哪，哇。多么疯狂的世界。想象一下，这里有一个人，她是你的妈妈，她是你爸爸的妻子。
Everybody loves her. Your dad has these feelings. He wants her to be buried next to her son. Like, all this fucking, like, it's all about love and love of people, and there's fucking religion, whether whichever one it is, take your pick,
每个人都爱她。你爸爸有这些感情。他想让她和她的儿子埋在一起。就像，所有这些他妈的，就像，这全是为了爱和对人的爱，然后偏偏有他妈的宗教，无论哪个宗教，随便你挑一个，
sticking his fucking nose in and ruining the experience of people who are just fucking grieving and in love with each other and that is such fucking bullshit. Like that is fucking, that is crazy. Yeah, well, what's crazier is that he was naked in our kitchen
把它的狗鼻子伸进来，毁掉了那些正他妈的在悲伤中、彼此相爱的人的体验，这他妈的太扯淡了。就像那他妈的，那太疯狂了。对，嗯，更疯狂的是，一周后他在我们的厨房里和他的清洁女工赤身裸体。所以他显然对妈妈的去世看得很开。但他的脚在那期间很暖和，对吧？他是不是只留着袜子？
a week later with his cleaning lady. So he obviously took my mom's death very hard. But his feet were warm all that, right? Did he keep just the socks. Oh, no, yeah, he had a socks on. Yeah, he had a socks on. Yeah. That's where he... He took your mom's death semi-hard.
哦，没有，对，他穿着袜子。对，他穿着袜子。对。那就是他……你妈妈的去世让他感到半硬不软。不错。我听说。不错。传言说，直接穿进他的袜子。那你有，关于摩门教的任何东西有没有渗透到家里？还是说更像是如果父亲是摩门教徒，就会有很多妻子和孩子在周围？或者你来自一个大家庭？你怎么敢？
Nice. I heard. Nice. The rumor was, right into his socks. Now, did you, what about any of the Mormon stuff make its way into the house? Or is it more like if the father is a Mormon, then there's a lot of wives around and kids around. Or do you come from a big family? How dare you?
首先，你怎么敢？我不太确定。我对所有这些东西都很生疏。关于摩门教？对，嗯，我们实际上在盐湖城住过一段时间。所以我多少知道一点，但又不是真的了解。总之。对，它对很多人来说有点像切身相关，就像我们很多人一样。我们多少知道一点。我记得我读过《摩门经》。我妈妈，因为我妈妈在我哥哥去世后变得笃信宗教了。你知道，每个人都用那种方式来处理他们的悲伤。就像人们生病了。他们变得笃信宗教。他们变得愤怒。他们把它藏起来。我妈妈重新深度参与到了教会中。因为在此之前，她只是像个犹太母亲那样操持着，比如在我们所有兄弟姐妹的成人礼上。我是六个孩子中的一个。我妈妈会站在寺庙的讲台（Bima）上，
First of all, how dare you? I'm not sure. I'm rusty on all this stuff. On Mormonism? Yeah, well, we actually lived in Salt Lake City for a while. So I know it sort of, kind of, but not really. Anyway. Yeah, it's kind of adjacent to a lot of people, like a lot of us. We kind of know a little bit. I remember I read the book of Mormon. My mom, because my mom got religious after my brother died. You know, everybody handles their grief like that. Like people get sick. They get religious. They get angry. They hide it away. My mom got really back involved with the church. Because before that, she was just carrying on like a Jewish mother, like at all of our bat mitzvahs and bar mitzvahs, my brothers and sisters. I'm one of six kids. My mom would be on the Bima at, you know, at the temple. singing Hebrew prayers.
用希伯来语唱着祈祷文。所以当我发现她不是犹太人时，我就想，等等，什么？所以这非常令人困惑。但我的妈妈让我的一个妹妹肖莎娜也皈依了。她也成了摩门教徒。她现在终于从中恢复过来了。但我记得我大约11岁时读过《摩门经》。摩门教怎么会允许一个叫肖莎娜的人进去？
So when I found out she wasn't Jewish, I was like, wait, what? So it was very confusing. But my mom converted my one sister, Shoshana. She became Mormon, too. She's now finally recovering from that. But I remember reading the book of Mormon when I was like 11. How does the Mormon church even allow a Shoshana in there?
肖莎娜，应该这么说，你根本进不了门。他们什么人都收，没错。没有任何先决条件。查尔斯，你的父母是否，这算是个有点无聊的问题，但我很感兴趣，你的父母是否支持
Shoshana, it should be, you can't get through the door. They'll take anyone, exactly. There's no prerequisite. Charles, were your parents like, kind of a boring question, but I'm interested, were your parents supportive
你去做喜剧或进入娱乐界？他们有没有那种反应：你在干什么？我不明白你为什么要走这条路。不，我父母，当我离开时，你不明白那种类型，我成长的时候简直是个小恶魔。
and you going to comedy or the entertainment business at all? Were they like, what are you doing? I don't understand why you're going there. No, my parents, when I left, you don't understand the kind, I was a hell on wheels when I grew up.
我就是，无论别人叫我做什么，我都反着来，叫他们滚蛋，你知道的，老师、任何权威，就像，权威人物，我父母双方都是。所以当我搬到洛杉矶时，我想我来洛杉矶时大概19岁。而他们当时就觉得，这才是对的。
I was just, whatever anybody told me to do, I did the opposite and told them to fuck off, you know, teachers, any authority, like, authority figures, both of my parents. So by the time I moved to L.A., I think I was 19 years old when I came out to L.A. And they were just like, this is the right thing.
你应该去。所有人对我以及对我的家庭都受够了，所以他们很高兴我能离开。我前几天还在讲这个故事。我哥哥，我当时正开车横跨美国。我爸爸是个二手车商。所以他给了我一辆奥迪Quattro，这辆二手奥迪Quattro，
You should go. Everyone was so over me and my family that they were happy. I was leaving. And I was telling the story the other day. My brother, I was driving cross-country. My dad was a used car dealer. So he gave me this like Audi-quatro, this used Audi-quotro,
我知道我一横跨美国它就会抛锚，如果我甚至能开到的话。而我哥哥，出于保护，你知道，保护欲，过度保护，说，你为什么不，我昨晚在酒吧遇到一个酒保，他也想横跨美国。你为什么不跟他一起开车横跨美国？聪明。这样你就不是一个人了。
which I knew was going to break down as soon as I got a cross-country if I even made it. And my brother, being as protective, you know, protective, overprotective, said, why don't you, I met this bartender last night in a bar, and he wants to go across country too. Why don't you drive with him across country? Smart. So you're not alone.
哦，天哪。然后我就想，嗯。他说，那样更安全，切尔西。然后我就想，对，但这可不是什么好推荐。我的意思是，你昨晚才刚在酒吧遇到这家伙。但当然，我还是觉得，好吧。所以我去接了这个家伙。他的名字叫安迪·迪克。
Oh, my God. And I was like, hmm. And he goes, it's safer that way, Chelsea. And I was like, yeah, but this isn't a great endorsement. I mean, you just met this guy last night at a bar. But of course, I was like, sure. So I pick up the guy. His name was Andy Dick.
安迪·迪克。对，其实是安迪·迪克，还有大卫·斯佩德。而且是两个人。那家伙是两个人。那是双胞胎。我就像，你们是……哦，天哪。
Andy Dick. Yeah, it was Andy Dick, actually. It was David Spade and Andy Dick And he was two guys The guy was two guys It was twins I was like are you guys Oh my God
他说是一个人。然后他们就开始繁殖了。那家伙对我说，他问，嘿，你要不要去城里搞点可卡因来路上用？我当时19岁。这还是在我发现……
He said one guy And they just started multiplying And the guy says to me He goes Hey do you want to go get some Coke In the city for the trip And I was 19 And this was before I had discovered
是贝特曼吗？是你接的贝特曼吗？不是。我确实喜欢贝特曼的古柯碱故事。但不是他。伙计们，让她来揭晓谜底吧。好啦。你扯得太远了。然后那家伙说，我们去搞点可卡因吧。
Was it Bateman? Was it Bateman that you picked up? It was it I do like Bateman's cocaine stories But it wasn't him Guys let her do the big reveal All right You're jumping ahead. And the guy goes, let's get some Coke.
然后我就想，好吧。于是我们开车进纽约市。他去拿他的可卡因，对吧？我们在车里。我甚至不知道我这辈子当时有没有吸过可卡因。然后我，我们上车开始开。大概要开五个小时。我们从新泽西出发。
And I was like, all right. So we drive into New York City. He picks up his Coke, right? We're in the car. I don't even know if I had ever done cocaine at this point of my life. And I, we get in the car and we're driving. It's like a five-hour drive. We left from New Jersey.
我想我们最后到了马里兰州的某个地方，因为我们要往南开，去走那条不知什么的路线。对。然后我们到了一个酒店房间。我们订了两个床。我们登记入住，他开始吸可卡因。我就想，真的吗，第一晚？我就想，这接下来要怎么搞？
And I think we ended up somewhere in Maryland because we were heading down south to go down that whatever route it is. Right. And we get to a hotel room. We get two beds. And we check in, and he starts doing the Coke. And I was like, really, the first night? I was like, how's this going to work?
然后他把地图拿出来。当然。这还是在，你知道，我们的手机还没有……的时候。他把地图拿出来，铺满了整个房间，一边吸着可卡因，一边试图找出我们能走的各种路线。然后我就想，哦，我他妈的上帝。听起来是个美妙的夜晚。他应该把可卡因铺成路线。
And then he got maps out. Sure. This was before, you know, our cell phone did it have here. He got maps out and he was laying them all across the room while he was snort in Coke and trying to figure out different routes that we could take. And I was like, oh, my fucking God. Sounds like a great night. He should have laid down the Coke in the route.
正在发生。而且这太烦人了。他嘴巴还停不下来。他不停地讲啊讲。我说，老兄，你得闭嘴了。我得睡觉。我在开车。显然你永远无法再开车了，
Happening. And it was so annoying. And he wouldn't shut up. He just kept talking and talking. I go, dude, you've got to stop talking. I have to sleep. I'm driving. Clearly, you're never going to be able to drive again
因为我们房间里有一磅的可卡因。然后我就想，如果他在我值班时死掉怎么办？不，他会先试图亲你。他有没有试图再亲你？对，当然，对。我去睡觉了。我醒来。他在我里面。
because there's a pound of cocaine in our room. And then I was like, what if he dies on my watch? No, he's going to try to kiss you first. Did he try to kiss you again? Yeah, of course, yeah. I go to sleep. I woke up. He was inside of me.
我去睡觉了。我敢打赌当时并不硬吧。我醒来，他一整晚都没睡，还在研究地图，他说，我觉得我们可以走这条路，我觉得我们可以走这条路，然后我就想，这绝对不可能发生。于是我拿着我的手提箱，
I go to sleep. I bet it wasn't hard, though. I wake up and he's still up from the night. before with the maps and he's like, I think we could go this way and I think we could go this way and I was like, there's no way this is happening. So I take my suitcase,
我说，嘿，我想把我们的东西放到车里。我拿了我们俩的手提箱。我把他的放在房间外面，把我的放进后备箱，然后我就直接开着车离开了我们所在的那个马里兰州的酒店，自己一个人把剩下的路程开完了，把他甩在身后大约五个小时的车程外。
I go, hey, I want to go put our stuff in the car. I take both of our suitcases. I leave his right outside our room and I take mine, I put it in the trunk and I just pulled out of that like Maryland hotel that we were in and drove the rest of the way across country by myself and left him about five hours out.
你后来还听到过他的消息吗？我哥哥就像是，等我到了加州，我说，多亏了那个白痴。然后他说，我听说你把他留在马里兰了。我就想，对，我是留那了。他说，对，他不得不一路坐出租车回来。他说花了2000美元。顺便说一句，他还在告诉出租车司机该怎么走，
I've ever hear from him again? My brother was like, once I got to California, I was like, thanks a lot for that idiot. And he goes, I heard you left him in Maryland. I was like, yeah, I did. And he said, yeah, he had to take a taxi all the way back. He said it was $2,000. By the way, telling the taxi driver where to go
哪条路线最好。真是个混蛋。对，那个出租车司机，可能，对，那个出租车司机当时就像是，其实原本是500美元，直到你开始说话。所以现在是2000美元。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以当你来到洛杉矶时，你19岁。
and which route is best still. What a fucking. Yeah, that taxi driver, it was probably, yeah, that taxi driver was like, actually, it was $500 until you started talking. So now it's $2,000. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So when you got out to L.A., you're 19 years old.
对，你把车开进来，你上了高速公路。你接下来去哪？第一站是哪里？你想做什么？我只是想让别人听到我的声音。我当时觉得我有强烈的观点，而且我认为我有很多错位的自信，我相信人们会从听到我要说的话中受益。
Yeah, you pull in, you're on the fucking freeway. What do you go? What's the first stop? What would you want to do? I just wanted people to hear. I just felt like I had strong opinions and I thought I had a lot of misplaced confidence and I believed that people would benefit from hearing what I had to say.
就像，我真的相信我自己的想法是有价值的，而且我将以某种方式做出贡献。说实话，我可能只是渴望得到关注。基本上就是这样。但我希望把它弄得稍微成熟一点，或者，你知道的。然后我和住在贝弗利格伦的姑妈和姑父住在一起。他们有九个孩子。我成了他们的某种保姆。
Like, I really believed that my own thoughts were valuable and that I was going to make a contribution in some way. I think I was just thirsty, you know, for the attention, to be honest. That's just basically what it was. but I wanted to make it into something a little bit more sophisticated or, you know. And then I lived with my aunt and uncle who lived in on Beverly Glen. They had nine children. And I became their kind of nanny.
每天早上我开着一辆小型客车送这些孩子们去上学，同时听着霍华德·斯特恩的节目。我开始端盘子。然后我就想，好吧，我在这里到底要干什么？就像，我要怎么才能被发掘？就像，我只是假设会有人看到我然后说，哦，好吧，跟我们走吧。第一步是什么？你是去喜剧商店了吗？你是去即兴喜剧俱乐部了吗？
And I would drive these kids to school every morning in a minivan while I was listening to Stern. And I just started waiting tables. And then I was like, all right, what the fuck am I going to do out here? Like, how am I going to get discovered? Like, I just assumed somebody would see me and be like, oh, okay, come with us. And what was first? Did you just, did you go to the comedy store? Did you go to the improv?
你是找了经纪人吗？第一步是什么？嗯，我去，我在21岁时因酒驾（DUI）被捕。不寻常的路线。好的开始。不寻常。是的，坦白说，既不寻常又出人意料。我想指出的是，我从那以后再也没有过，因为我喜欢吸取第一次的教训，
Did you like get an agent? What was first? Well, I went to, I got a DUI when I was 21 years old. Unusual route. Good start. Unusual. Yes, unusual and unexpected, quite frankly. And I'd like to note that I have never had one since because I like to learn my lesson the
让它成为最后一次。不管怎样，我酒驾被抓了，我不得不去上酒驾课程。这基本上是他们把你塞进的一个系统，在里面他们教你如何摆脱下一次酒驾。所以他们会告诉你，比如如果你被警察拦下，你一开口说你喝了酒，你就完蛋了。就像，你必须永远说没有，否认，否认，否认。然后我就想，等等，这是什么课？你们基本上是在教我们如何避免再次被捕，而且这还是由州政府出资的。对。
first time and make it the last time. But anyway, I got my DUI and I had to go to DUI class. which is basically a system that they put you in where they teach you how to get out of your next DUI. So they tell you, like, if you get pulled over the minute you say you've had something to drink, you're screwed. Like, you always have to say no, deny, deny, deny. And I was like, wait, what is this class? You're just basically teaching us how to avoid getting arrested again and it's being paid for by the state. Right.
然后每个人都得站起来讲述他们酒驾的故事。所以我当时真的、真的很害怕，因为我不太喜欢公开演讲，而且我也不知道。所以每个星期我都会躲在教室后面，心想：别他妈的叫我。我不知道我要说什么。
And then everyone had to get up and tell their DUI story. And so I was really, really scared because I didn't like public speaking and I didn't know. So I would just kind of hide in the back of the class every week like don't fucking pick on me. I don't know what I'm going to say.
我不知道我的故事是什么。而在最后一节课上，他已经没有其他人可叫了。我不得不站起来，我记得那种感觉，就像当你非常紧张时，你的腿在发抖。我当时就想，哦，天哪。我站到台上去，开始讲述我的故事，然后大家就开始哈哈大笑，
I don't know what my story is. And on the very last class, he was out of people. And I had to get up and I remember just like, you know, when you're so nervous, your leg is shaking. And I just was like, oh my God. And I got up there and I started telling my story and everyone just started laughing and laughing
因为我把警察叫作种族主义者。我们两个都是白人。你知道的，我做的所有事。我在西博尔布兰德县监狱呆了大约24个小时，因为他们无法把我弄进系统，直到他们把我弄进系统。而我就是这样一个，你知道的，自以为是的来自新泽西的犹太小女孩，当时的想法是：什么？
because like I called the cop racist. We were both white. you know, everything I did. I was in Sybil Brand County Jail for like 24 hours because they couldn't get me out of the system until they got me into the system. And here I am this, you know, white entitled little Jersey Jewish girl who was like, what?
西博尔布兰德。我只找了一个我能找到的最大、最胖的黑人女性，然后我说，我们做朋友吧。在那之后，在我发言并做了那件事之后，人们就说，你应该去演单口喜剧。然后我想，哦，这主意真棒。我应该去演单口喜剧。你知道的，你独自一人站在舞台上拿着麦克风，这正是你所追求的。
Sybil Brand. I just found the biggest, fatest black woman I could find. And I was like, let's be friends. And after that, after I spoke and I did that, people were like, you should do stand-up. And then I thought, oh, that's a great idea. I should do stand-up. You know, you on stage alone with a microphone is exactly what you're after.
所以这就是我开始表演单口喜剧的时候。因此，我确实把那个酒驾课程归功于它给了我这个灵感，因为如果人们没有那样对我说，我不知道自己是否会想到去独自表演单口喜剧。但有趣的是，它其实就在那里。在你站上去之前它就在那里；你只是需要某种东西把它从你体内引出来，对。对，需要一个小出口把它从我体内引出来。
So that's when I started doing stand-up. So I do credit that DUI class with giving me the idea because if people hadn't said that to me, I don't know that I would have thought about doing stand-up on my own. But it's interesting that it was in there. It was in there before you got up there. You just needed some kind of something to pull it out of you, yeah. Yeah, a little outlet to pull it out of me.
你有想过追踪那个把你抓起来的警察并感谢他给了你这个职业吗？不，我没想过那个。我其实一直在等你去做这件事，威尔。这是你觉得做起来会觉得舒服的事吗？我当然愿意。当然。所以，查尔斯，你知道的，看起来在过去这大约十年里，你已经，你从你那令人难以置信的搞笑单口喜剧和电视节目中转变了过来，
Did you ever think about tracking down that police officer who busted you and thanking him for your career? No, I haven't thought about that. I was actually going to wait for you to do that, Will. Is that something you feel comfortable doing? Of course I do. Of course. So, Charles, you know, it seems like in like the last decade or so, you've been, you've gone from your unbelievably hilarious stand-up to, and television shows,
在这些节目中，你知道，你的幽默流露于从观察式喜剧到朋友和家人之间的方方面面，但随后发生了一个转变，你开始涉足更多政治和世界问题，这些对你很重要，而且你至今仍充满热情？对你来说，那个转折点是什么？是不是有什么事件或者什么事情，你知道的，稍微转移了你的注意力？是的，这就是所谓的选举，西恩，2016年的选举。不，我不知道在此之前是不是这样。
where, you know, your humor comes out from everything from like observational comedy to friends and family, everything in between, but then a shift happens. where you got into kind of more political and world issues and that mattered to you and that you still feel passionate about? And what was that turning point for you? Was there an event or something that, you know, shifted your focus a little bit? Yeah, it was called the election, Sean, of 2016. No, I didn't know if it was before that.
我不知道在此之前是不是这样。不，我是说，那真的让我到了一个地方，我当时就想，哦，天哪，美国要完蛋了。就像，我们过时了。也就是在那时你的书出版了，也就是在那时你写了书……对，所以那是，就像，我经历了一段非常困难的时期。那是在，就在我的网飞（Netflix）节目结束的时候，我，也就是那时我开始接受心理治疗。我当时太……就像，你知道的，他们说你的愤怒，一切都为你服务，直到
I didn't know if it was before that. No, I mean, that just really got me to a place where I just thought, oh, God, America's going to be over. Like, we're a passe. And that's when your book had, and that's when you wrote your book and... Yeah, so that was, like, I went through a really difficult time. It was after, right, as my Netflix show was ending, and I, that's when I got into therapy. And I was just so, it's like, you know, they say your anger, everything works for you until
它不再为你服务，对吧？对。而那正是对我来说一切达到顶峰的时候，我在情绪上简直就像是，哦，我需要在这里寻求一些帮助了。就像，我不再过得好了。以前对我有用的东西现在对我没用了。所以这其中有一个巨大的转变。我变得非常政治化，你知道的，人们对此感到非常恼火。
it doesn't, right? Yeah. And that was kind of when everything came to a head for me where I was emotionally just like, oh, I need to get some help here. Like, I'm not doing great anymore. And what was working for me before isn't working for me now. So there was a big shift in that. And I got really political, you know, and people got really annoyed by that.
而且我是，但我觉得我不得不这样。我只是无法对此保持沉默。我就是不能。这就好像如果你不说点什么，那这说明了你是个什么样的人？而我不是那种人，你知道的？有时我真希望自己能闭嘴。而在那之前，你并没有那么，
And I was, but I felt like I had to. I just couldn't be quiet about that. I just couldn't. It's like if you don't say something, then what does that say about you? And I'm not like that, you know? I wish I could shut up sometimes. And before that, you weren't just as,
我不知道，我不想替你说话，但就像你没有那么关注政治，或者你没有受到它们那样的方式影响？这样说公平吗？不，我是关注（attuned）政治。是关注（attuned），而不是合拍（in tune）。而且我受到了它的影响。也许你待会儿可以过来。
I don't know, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but like in tune to politics or you weren't as affected by them in that way? Is that fair? No, I was attuned to politics. It's attuned, not in tune. And I was affected by it. Maybe you can come over later.
我知道。我不得不纠正你。我知道，我喜欢这样。但我当时，一切都挺好的。我们有巴拉克·奥巴马，我以为事情正在改变。在我天真的、你知道的那种小泡沫里，我心想，哦，世界是个好地方。看看繁荣的美国。所以我当时没有那么激烈和大声。
I know. I was to have to correct you. I know, I love it. But I was, it was going well. We had Barack Obama and I thought things were changing. In my naive, you know, little bubble, I'm like, oh, the world's a great place. Look at America thriving. So I wasn't as vehement and loud.
对，对，对，对。直到那件事发生。你觉得，你是否感到满足或欣慰，因为你所做的事情正在带来某种改变？或者，仅仅能够说出你的心声就已经足够了，如果有什么好事从中产生，那就太好了。但在此之前，至少我在说出自己的心声。嗯，我做了很多事情。比如我进行了一场全国各地的大学校园巡回演出，
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Until that. Did you feel that, were you satisfied or pacified that what you were doing was affecting some change? Or was it just enough to sort of just be able to speak your mind and, if anything good comes from it, then great. But until then, at least I'm speaking my mind. Well, I did a lot of stuff. Like I went on a tour across country to colleges and campuses,
去，你知道的，与保守派辩论，谈论选举，了解为什么人们会那样做。我为那么多最终在期中选举中当选的候选人付出了巨大的努力。所以当你看到一个有形的事件，你知道的，或者说具体的证据——我是指你的努力的成果，而不仅仅是我个人的，显然有数以百万计的人在做和我一样的事情——所以，是的，这感觉真的很棒，参与到那个过程中感觉很好，感觉很充实，你知道的，就像我生活中的一切一样，我做什么都用150%的力气，然后，你知道的，我就想，好吧，我受够这个了，你知道，然后我们迎来了这位总统，我们正在应付这些破事，然后你就会想，哦，天哪，这种循环永远不会结束。所以我过去几个星期都不看报纸了，因为这真的会影响你，还会让你的血压升高，而你想成为一个有效的……欢迎加入俱乐部。
to, you know, debate conservatives, to talk about the election, to understand why people did that. And I worked really hard for so many candidates that ended up getting elected in the midterm. So you do feel like it is fruitful when you can see like a tangible event, you know, or concrete evidence, I should say,
对，没错。没错。我是说真的。不，不，不。这些家伙知道，我一直都在说，我大概在一年半以前，
of your efforts and not just mine obviously millions of people were doing the same thing as I was so yeah it felt really good it felt good to be involved in that process it felt full on you know and just like everything in my life I do everything like 150 percent and then you know I'm like okay I'm done with this you know and then we get this president and we're dealing with this shit and you're just like oh my god it's never ending this kind of cycle so I've stopped reading the paper for the last couple weeks because it's just it really does you and it raises your blood pressure and you want to be an effective... Welcome to the club. Yeah, right. Right. I'm serious. No, no, no. These guys know, I talk about it all the time that I, about a year and a half ago
关掉了我数字录像机（DVR）上所有的有线新闻频道。我实在受不了了，因为我觉得，归根结底，首先，并不是说你不会发现正在发生的事情。在我们生活的世界里，这几乎是不可能的。而且我不需要全天候24小时被提醒这些，我也不需要让它影响到我，以至于让我觉得——天哪，我讨厌“有毒”（toxic）这个词——但确实是有毒的，
I turned off all the cable news things in my DVR. I can't take it anymore because I was like, well, ultimately, first of all, it's not like you're not going to find out about the stuff that's going on. It's virtually impossible in the world that we live in. And I don't need to be reminded of a 24-7 and I don't need to have it affect me to the point where I feel, God, I hate the word toxic, but toxic,
就好像它感觉随时随地在渗透你的整个存在。对，这真是一件扫兴的事。这是一件非常扫兴的事。我们马上回来。抱歉。对，我们换个话题。这不是，好吧，我们开始吧。
where it's just like it feels like it sort of permeates your entire being at all times. Yeah, it's a bummer. It's a big bummer. We'll be right back. Sorry. Yeah, let's change the subject. It's not, okay, here we go.
我的意思是，耶稣他妈的基督，西恩，你把我们引上了这条毁灭之路。我知道，西恩，对。看在老天的份上，她正在进行喜剧巡演。我们回到宗教上来吧。不，我们会回到宗教上。那只是一些乐趣。不，我们别提那些高度敏感的话题了。谋杀怎么样？
I mean, Jesus fucking Christ, Sean, you set us on this path of destruction. I know, Sean, yeah. She's doing a comedy tour for fuck's sake. Let's get back to religion. No, we'll get back to religion. That's just some fun. No, we stop with the hot button. What about murder?
赌博怎么样？赌博。我们来谈谈……我们来谈谈生病的儿童。小狗怎么样？动物呢？你喜欢动物，对吧？我们来聊聊动物吧。
How about gambling? Gambling. Let's talk about... Let's talk about sick children. What about puppies? How about animals? You love animals, right? Let's talk about some animals.
哦，我的动物们一点也不尊重我，伙计们。在新冠疫情期间第一次和我的家人待在一起时，我就想，去他妈的。我的狗觉得我是……它们觉得我的管家是它们的救星，而它们把我当作它们的监护人。它们……这太
Oh, my animals do not respect me, you guys. Being alone with my family, for the first time during COVID, I was like, fuck this. My dogs think that I'm... They think my housekeeper is their rescuer, and they treat me like I'm their conservator. They are... It was so deep. demoralizing being alone with my dogs for the first time during COVID. And I went to Whistler. I went skiing because I love to ski. And I thought, well, I'm not going to spend four months
令人沮丧了，在新冠期间第一次独自和我的狗待在一起。我去了惠斯勒。我去滑雪了，因为我喜欢滑雪。我想，好吧，我才不在洛杉矶的家里待四个月呢。我要去惠斯勒。我第一次独自带着我的狗。它们会直勾勾地盯着我的眼睛，然后在我们的飞机上直接随地小便，你知道的。对，我很清楚。直勾勾地看着我的眼睛。就像，你他妈的是不是在开玩笑，你觉得你能照顾我们？我带它们去散步，我刚到惠斯勒的第一天，在这个小小的私人社区里，对吧？我带着我的狗去散步，大概是我得到它们以来第一次带它们散步。说实话吧。说真的。
in L.A. in my house. I'll go to Whistler. And I had my dogs for the first time alone with me. They would just look me in the eye and just spot piss, you know, in our plane. Yeah, I know it. Look me in the eye. Like, are you fucking, are you kidding me that you think you're going to look after us? I would take them for, I took them for a walk. The first day I'm in Whistler, I'm in this little private neighborhood, right? And I'm taking my dogs for a walk, probably for the first time since I got them. Let's be honest. Let's be real.
在洛杉矶我的家里。我要去惠斯勒。那是我第一次单独带着我的狗。它们就直勾勾地盯着我的眼睛，然后直接在我们的飞机里撒尿，你知道的。是的，我懂。直视着我的眼睛。好像在说，你他妈的，你在开玩笑吧，你觉得你能照顾好我们？我带它们去，我带它们去散步。我在惠斯勒的第一天，在一个很小的私人社区里，对吧？我带着我的狗去散步，大概是我得到它们以来第一次吧。说实话吧。说真的。
Because I had to go to Whistler alone. You know, it was COVID. Nobody could get in. And so I'm walking them. And they're brother-sister chow-chows. They're from the same litter. And they're rescues. I want to put that in there just so Pete it doesn't fucking bump me up.
因为我不得不独自去惠斯勒。你知道，那是疫情期间。谁也进不去。所以我得带它们散步。它们是两只周犬，是一窝生的兄妹。它们是领养的。我想把这个加进去，这样皮特就不会生我的气了。
I've had problems with them in the past. Sure. So I took them for a walk one morning. And this woman, and I didn't have them on leashes because my dogs are so lazy. They can't even run, you know? They're just like. And I'm walking around the course. corner and this woman sees them.
我过去和它们有过一些问题。当然。所以我有一天早晨带它们去散步。有个女人，我当时没给它们栓绳，因为我的狗太懒了。它们甚至都跑不动，你知道吗？它们就那样。然后我绕过拐角，这个女人看到了它们。
She goes, and I'm like, really? She goes, there's no leashes. You don't have it. Leashes on the dogs. And I said, they're not aggressive. Like, okay, I'll get the leashes, but they're not going to do anything.
她说，我心想，真的吗？她说，没有栓绳。你没有给狗栓绳。我说，它们不咬人。好吧，我去拿绳子，但它们不会干什么的。
And she's like, it's not for me. It's not for me. I mean, somebody might see them and think they're bears. And they're like one feet tall. They're both wearing handkerchiefs, first of all. So nobody's going to think that. But yeah, my dogs, after I took them from home from Whistler,
然后她说，这不是为了我。这不是为了我。我是说，别人看见了可能会以为那是熊。而且它们只有一尺高。首先，它们都戴着手绢。所以没人会这么想。不过是的，我的狗，在我把它们从惠斯勒带回家之后，
I just, my cleaning lady was like, when I came home, I realized, like, I just, that was abusive to take them with me because I don't have the same level of attention to them that she does. You know, I don't know if she has peanut butter in her underwear or what she's up to. But those dogs, when they're with her, they thrive. And when with me, it feels like they're going to cross over. I'm going to put jelly in mine and just come over and we're going to be a family. That doesn't work for dogs, honey.
我只是，我的清洁工当时，当我回家时我意识到，我只是，把它们带在身边简直是对它们的虐待，因为我对它们的关注程度不如她。你知道的，我不知道她内裤里是不是塞了花生酱还是在搞什么鬼。但那些狗跟她在一起时就长得特别好。而跟我在一起时，感觉它们随时都会驾鹤西去。我要在我的内裤里抹点果冻然后过来，我们就能成为一家人了。那对狗可不管用，亲爱的。
Unless you have a, maybe a cat. Do you have a cat? Oh, you do have a cat. Thank you. No, Scottie's... You should. All right. So listen.
除非你有一只，也许是猫。你有猫吗？哦，你确实有一只猫。谢谢。不，斯科蒂……你应该有的。好吧。所以听我说。
Chalce, you know, you... Go ahead, Sean. You got another question? Fucking, yeah, don't let anybody else chime in here on Chelsea. Oh, my God. Go ahead. This is the most I've talked on this podcast
切尔斯，你知道，你……说吧，肖恩。你还有问题吗？他妈的，是的，别让其他人在这里对切尔斯指手画脚。哦，天哪。说吧。这是我在这个播客里说得最多的一次
and we started. I know. By the way, I've listened to this podcast, Sean, and this is the most you've spoken. So, Joe, it is. It's because I get excited when I see you. Jason's on his only fans page. Look at Jason.
自从我们开始。我知道。顺便说一句，肖恩，我听过这个播客，这确实是你说话最多的一次。所以，乔，确实是。那是因为看到你我很兴奋。杰森正在他的OnlyFans主页上。看杰森。
Look at him down there. He wishes he knew what that was. Are you kidding? What is only fans? There he go. What is only fans? Truly, is that a thing? Yeah, it is a thing.
看他在下面。他希望他知道那是什么。你在开玩笑吗？什么是OnlyFans？他去了。什么是OnlyFans？真的，那是个东西吗？对，是个东西。
You'll fight out about it. Now that you've heard it once, you'll hear it again. Unbelievable. Charles, I heard you on your, by the way, you have a fantastic podcast. I love it. You're so funny. Thank you. On it, you said, you were talking about something about funerals like, I can't remember if it.
你会弄明白的。既然你已经听过一次了，你还会再听到它的。难以置信。查尔斯，我听说过你的，顺便说一句，你有一个极棒的播客。我喜欢。你太搞笑了。谢谢。在节目里你说过，你谈到了关于葬礼的事情，比如，我记不清是不是了。
Oh, getting hit on at a funeral. Yeah, or not. Did you say it was okay to get hit on a funeral? It's not okay to get hit on a funeral. It's not okay. I mean, it's not appropriate. And even if you liked a man or were into him and wanted to have sex with him, if he did that at a funeral,
哦，在葬礼上被人搭讪。是的，还是没有。你说过在葬礼上被人搭讪是可以的吗？在葬礼上被人搭讪是不行的。这不可以。我的意思是，这很不合时宜。即使你喜欢一个男人或者对他动心并想和他发生性关系，如果他在葬礼上这么做，
it's so not hot that you can never do that. Well, what about your crying? You need a shoulder to cry on. Has that happened to you? Has somebody hit on you at a funeral? What if it's open casket? I know, but I heard a story recently about two very famous people at a funeral,
这也太不性感了，你绝不能那么做。好吧，那你的哭泣呢？你需要一个可以依靠哭泣的肩膀。这种事发生在你身上过吗？有人在葬礼上搭讪过你吗？如果是开棺瞻仰呢？我知道，但我最近听到一个关于两个非常有名的人在葬礼上的故事，
making out at a funeral. At my friend, yes. And she told me that they were on top of each other at a memorial service. Wait. Oh my God. Making out like tongue kissing. And I'm like, you fucking have to be kidding me.
在葬礼上热吻。在我朋友那，是的。她告诉我，他们在追悼会上压在对方身上。等等。哦，天哪。像法式热吻那样。而我想，你他妈的一定是在开玩笑。
It's so disrespectful. Well, it was at the wake. It wasn't at the ceremony, right? No, is that a memorial? But still, whatever. It's still a memorial and it's still fucking hot as hell. Really rude. Interesting.
这太不尊重人了。好吧，那是在守灵时。不是在仪式上，对吧？不，那是追悼会吗？但不管怎样，随便吧。那仍然是一个追悼会，而且依然他妈的性感得要命。真的很粗鲁。有趣。
But depends. Were they good-looking people? Yeah. It depends. Yeah, they're both good-looking people. Well, that's pretty fucking great. I mean, watching good-looking people make out, I don't care where you are. In front of a casket.
但视情况而定。他们长得好看吗？对。视情况而定。是的，他们俩都长得很好看。好吧，那可真他妈太棒了。我是说，看着长得好看的人热吻，我才不管你在哪。在棺材前面。
Right. And they're celebrities, so they should be able to do whatever they want anyway. Oh, they're celebrities. Let them do what they want. They're just like us, but they're not. I wonder if anybody got a stiff, get it? Hey, Chels, let me answer something else. You know, for the time.
对。而且他们是名人，所以无论如何他们应该能够做任何他们想做的事。哦，他们是名人。让他们做他们想做的事吧。他们就像我们一样，但又不是。我在想是不是有人有反应了，明白了吗？嘿，切尔斯，让我回答点别的。你知道，为了……
Oh, my God, Sean, we got to pause there for a second. Hold on a second. Where's Scotty? Sean, where's Scott? I hope those doors behind you burst open and somebody comes with piano wire and strangles you right now. Just fucking that's it.
哦，天哪，肖恩，我们得在那里暂停一下。等一下。斯科蒂在哪？肖恩，斯科特在哪？我希望你背后的那些门突然打开，有人拿着钢琴线现在就勒死你。就这样，他妈的。
Fucking Sean's, ugh. Okay, wait. You could take this microphone wire, Sean, and just do it. I'll do it myself. Um, no, just I wanted to know. For real, though, because for, for the time that I've known you, you seem like you're always, always, always, always on the go, go, go, go, go, go. Nonstop.
他妈的肖恩的，呃。好吧，等等。你可以用这个麦克风线，肖恩，直接动手就行。我自己来。嗯，不，只是我想知道。说真的，因为，就我认识你这么久以来，你看起来好像总是，总是，总是，一直在忙忙忙忙忙忙。从不停歇。
Who is your constant when you come back home or, or, you know, you hear this word a lot, like camp, like, camp. Like, who's in your camp or who are your constant people that you come back to all the time that you're like, ah, now I'm home? Uh, my family is like that. My family and I are pretty tight. So we spend a lot of times together. We go on vacations a lot together.
当你回到家时，谁是你的精神支柱，或者，你知道的，你经常听到这个词，比如阵营，比如，阵营。比如，谁在你的阵营里，或者谁是你经常回去的那些让你觉得，啊，我现在到家了的人？嗯，我的家人就是那样。我和我的家人关系很紧密。所以我们花很多时间在一起。我们经常一起去度假。
Oh, that's good. There are a lot of them. New Jersey, but, you know, not my dogs, obviously, and my family is pretty much my constant. I mean, my friends, you know, I have different groups of friends and lots of friends, and L.A. has been my home base for a long time, but I don't ever spend a long duration of time in L.A. I go in and out. Actually, COVID was the longest amount of time I ever spent in L.A. And my sister invaded my house with her three adult children, because apparently parenting never fucking ends. And I have, you know, designed my life in a way that I didn't ever want to have
哦，那很好。他们人很多。在新泽西，但是，你知道的，显然不是我的狗，我的家人基本上就是我的精神支柱。我的意思是，我的朋友，你知道的，我有不同的朋友圈和许多朋友，洛杉矶长期以来一直是我的大本营，但我从不在洛杉矶呆很长时间。我进进出出的。其实，疫情是我在洛杉矶呆过的最长的一段时间。我姐姐带着她三个成年孩子入侵了我的房子，因为显然做父母这事他妈的永远不会结束。而我，你知道的，我设计我生活的方式就是我从来不想有
children living in my house. So she came down for COVID for three months with her three adult children, 24, 21, and 18. And they stayed for three months. And then I put the house on the market and sold it, so that would never happen to me again. Are you serious? How did you let that happen? I, well, it was my sister. So obviously, I can't say no to family. But, and I thought, oh, this will be fun. I had, you know, the room. I have this great fun house. And, and And so they all came down, and then all of a sudden I was doing dinners every night at 7.30 with, you know, three kids. And every night somebody would cry. And then one, oh, and then my nephew, my nephew, he's 24 years old.
我家里住着一群孩子。因为疫情，她带着三个成年孩子（分别24岁、21岁和18岁）在我这儿住了三个月。他们住了整整三个月。然后我把房子挂牌卖了，这样这种事就绝不会再发生了。你是认真的吗？你怎么能让这种事发生？我，好吧，那是我的我妹妹。所以很明显，我对家人无法拒绝。但是，我当时想，哦，这会很有趣。你知道的，我有地方。我有这栋非常棒、很好玩的房子。而且，然后他们都搬来了，突然之间，我每天晚上7点半都要和三个孩子一起吃晚饭，你知道的。而且每天晚上都会有人哭。然后有一天，哦，然后我侄子，我侄子，他24岁了。
He's a sports journalist. And he was getting really frustrated during COVID, you know. He's like, I can't date. I'm like, date, buddy. Like, people are dying. We're in a global pandemic. Yeah. So one night, I go, she's like, do you know any funerals I could go to to pick up some chicks?
他是个体育记者。在疫情期间他真的很受挫，你知道的。他说：我没法约会。我说：约会啊，老兄。听着，人们都在死呢。我们在经历全球大流行。没错。所以有一天，我说，她就像是：你知道有什么葬礼我可以去泡妞吗？
Wait till somebody else dies in our family. We can hook you up. so he had an outdoor like an outdoor date in my backyard and my sister goes let me get you out of the house you're getting really irritated with everybody and i was like okay let's so we went for drinks at a friend's house uh probably marries and we came back and um he was at my kitchen counter my net my 24 year old nephew my first born nephew okay and he is acting like ernest hemingway just sitting at you know just you know really buzzed and really frustrated running his hands through his hair like he'd never been through so much And I was like, Jake, did you get, you know, did you get some penetration? What happened? I was like, no, Chelsea, of course I did it. And it's not funny. He's all backed up, huh?
等我们家有别人死了再说吧。我们可以帮你介绍。所以他在我后院进行了一次户外约会，我妹妹就说：我带你离开这房子吧，你对每个人都越来越烦躁了。我就说：好吧，走吧。所以我们去一个朋友家喝了杯饮料，可能是玛丽家，然后我们回来了。然后，他在我的厨房台子旁边，我24岁的侄子，我的长孙侄子，好吧，他表现得就像海明威一样，就坐在那儿，你知道的，喝得有点高而且非常沮丧，用手抓着头发，好像他从来没经历过这么多事。我就说：杰克，你，你知道的，你那个了吗？怎么回事？我就说：不，切尔西，我当然做了。这不好笑。他憋坏了吧，哈？
And I looked at him and I was like, no fucking way. Am I listening? I'm like, is this boy frustrated because he's horny? And I couldn't believe it. So I walked upstairs to my bedroom and my sister came up an hour later. She's like, sorry about that. I go, oh, sorry about that. Your job is to listen to your son, talk about how sexually frustrated he is
我看着他，心想：特么的有没有搞错？我居然在听这个？我想：这小子是因为发情才这么沮丧的吗？我简直不敢相信。所以我走上楼回到我的卧室，我妹妹一个小时后上楼来了。她说：真不好意思。我说：哦，真不好意思。你的工作就是听你儿子说他有多么性挫折
in the middle of this. pandemic what are you know i'm horny too but i can't fuck anybody because you guys won't get the fuck out of my house so anyway they left after that i would have come over Sean you've always been an amazing lover i love having sex with you Sean he doesn't i mean especially when you can't shut the fuck up while we're having sex you know you just drill me with one question after another i don't drill you with my penis just questions no you I drill me with questions. And now, back to the show.
在这场大流行的紧要关头，你们到底在—我也很饥渴，但我没法跟任何人上床，因为你们这群混蛋不肯滚出我的房子。总之，他们走后——要是我，我早就过来了，肖恩，你一直是个超级棒的情人，我超喜欢跟你做爱，肖恩。他才不呢，尤其是当你做爱时嘴巴闭不上的时候，你知道的，你一个接一个问题像钻头一样戳我。我才没有用阴茎钻你，我只是问问题。不，你用问题钻我。好了，言归正传。
Chelsea, you are in the middle of your tour or the beginning of it, or the end? I'm in the beginning of it. I'm announced 30 dates and I'm announcing 30 more. So I'm going to be on tour for the next year. So it's pretty fun. And we kicked it off at the Santa Barbara Bowl. I opened the Santa Barbara Bowl after two years. It was closed.
切尔西，你的巡演进行到中间，还是刚开始，还是快结束了？我才刚开始。我宣布了30场，现在又加了30场。所以我接下来的一年都要在巡演。这挺好玩的。我们在圣巴巴拉圆形剧场拉开了序幕。那是剧场关闭两年后我重新开启的。
So that was epic. It was the night of the full blue moon. So it was just such a great vibe. That's great. I love that. And, yeah, it's fun to be on tour. It's fun to be a reason people are coming back together for the first time and big groups. And, you know, my crowds are safe and they're vaccinated, so I have, you know, faith in that.
所以那太史诗级了。那天晚上正好是蓝满月。所以氛围真的超级好。太棒了。我很喜欢。而且，能在巡演感觉真好。成为大家第一次成群结队重新聚在一起的理由，这种感觉真棒。而且，你知道的，我的观众都很安全，都接种了疫苗，所以对此我很有信心。
And, yeah, I'm just loving doing stand-up again, you know. I want to get back to like- Did you have a, sorry, did you have a chance to work on your material even though there weren't a lot of places that were open during COVID? Yeah, yeah, I had a, I mean, I have been, I've been not, yeah, getting up for the last two months, putting my new hour together. But there's so much material from COVID. you know, trying to have sex during COVID. I had to get my own COVID test at my house. And then I would invite men over to the backyard
而且，是的，我真的很享受再次做单口喜剧，你知道的。我想回到——你有没有，抱歉，你有没有机会打磨你的段子，尽管疫情期间没几个地方开门？对，对，我有，我的意思是，我已经，我一直在，是的，过去两个月一直在登台，把我的新一小时专场拼凑起来。但疫情期间的素材实在太多了，你知道的，试图在疫情期间做爱。我不得不自己在家里做新冠检测。然后我会邀请男人们来后院
that I was getting set up with or whatever, and I'd give them a little nasal swab. And it takes like 20 to 30 minutes to run the diagnostics on that in my kitchen. And in that 20 to 30 minutes, I would interview them, you know, about see if they were a potential penetrator. And if they said anything in that time that was annoying or I saw a pinky ring,
我跟他们相亲或者别的什么，然后我会给他们做个小小的鼻拭子。在我的厨房里运行诊断测试大概需要20到30分钟。在这20到30分钟里，我会面试他们，你知道的，看看他们有没有潜力成为那个人。如果他们在那个时间内说的话很烦人，或者我看到一枚小指戒指，
I would just come back out and say, you're positive. you have to leave my house A pinky ring If anybody mentioned an aquarium They're positive Like just Yeah
我就会走出来对他们说：你阳了。你必须离开我的房子。小指戒指？如果有人提到水族馆，他们就是阳了。就像这样，是的。
Anybody you said masks don't work It's like get out of my house I can no longer fuck you Right right Wow Hey Charles When you go on tour Like you are
任何说口罩没用的人。这就好比：滚出我的房子，我再也不想跟你上床了。对，对，哇。嘿，查尔斯，当你去巡演的时候，就像你是
And do you have like a thing After the show's over Where you like Like any rituals or anything Where you meet and greet Where you come back To the hotel where you are Do you do something
演出结束后你有没有什么固定的流程？比如有什么仪式感之类的？比如见面会，或者回到你住的酒店，你会做点什么
Or just like straight to bed Or how late to stay up? Yeah I do a VIP meet and greet for other people that, you know, get the best tickets, you know, we do pictures after. But, you know, when you're on tour, it's pretty grueling. Like, being on stage for an hour and a half a night or an hour or whatever it ends up being is, like, I'm 46 years old, so I got to keep it tight. I don't really, you know, go out and party like I used to when I was on the road where it didn't matter. And I, you know, it didn't matter. You just,
还是直接上床睡觉？通常熬到多晚？对，我会为买到最好门票的人办一个VIP见面会，你知道的，我们之后会合影。但是，当你去巡演时，其实挺折磨人的。每晚在台上待一个半小时或一小时什么的，不管最后是多久，因为我46岁了，所以我得保持状态。我真的不会像以前在路上那样出去疯狂派对，那时候无所谓，怎么样都无所谓。你只是，
now it's like you want to be sharp, you want to have mental clarity. So, no, I don't really get after it in that way. And then it's like usually four nights of a weekend, you know, Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday night. Right. Do you ever go out and see other people stand up? Do you ever? Yeah, yeah, I do. I have been lately.
现在的情况是你想保持敏锐，想要思维清晰。所以，不，我不会那种疯狂玩乐。而且通常一个周末有四天，你知道的，周四、周五、周六、周日晚上。没错。你有没有去看过别人的单口喜剧？你有过吗？对，对，我有。我最近一直在看。
Like anybody you're a fan of now? Yeah, a lot of stand-ups. There's Hannah I have a lot of amazing women opening for me. Hannah Einbinder's awesome from Hacks. She opens for me. She opened for me in Vegas. Vanessa Gonzalez is a great female stand-up. A lot of women of color are opening for me, obviously,
比如你现在粉谁吗？对，很多单口喜剧演员。有汉娜，有很多优秀的女性为我暖场。汉娜·爱因宾格超级棒，来自《绝望hacks》。她为我暖场。她在拉斯维加斯为我暖场。凡妮莎·冈萨雷斯是一位出色的女性单口喜剧演员。很多有色人种女性都在为我暖场，显而易见，
because that's, you know, my, my, you want to give that stage time to everybody who hasn't gotten a fair shake at it. Yeah, for sure. And yeah, I just use different people all the time and I just love to bring girls in and yeah. I love that. I mean, what was the question, Sean? No, that's it. Yeah, Sean, what was the fucking question?
因为那是，你知道的，我的，你想要把舞台时间给那些一直没得到公平机会的人。对，确实如此。而且，是的，我一直在用不同的人，我就是喜欢把女孩们带上。是的，我喜欢这样。我是说，刚才的问题是什么来着，肖恩？不，就这样。是的，肖恩，刚才那个特么的问题是什么？
He wants to know what you do after because we're going to do a real stupid thing. We're going to go on tour. Oh, yeah, I saw that. We're dumbasses. And so Sean, I guess, is trying to figure out what his post-show routine is going to be. He wants to base it off what you do. And he wants to know, like,
他想知道你结束后会做什么，因为我们要干一件特别蠢的事。我们要去巡演了。哦，对，我看到了。我们都是大笨蛋。所以肖恩大概是在琢磨他演出结束后的常规流程会是什么样。他想根据你的做法来定。他想知道，比如，
Can he, can we hit the bars? Can he, can he mingle it up with people? Or maybe just go back to the hotel, get in the Schwitz. And, like, where he's got to do like, no, Scotty, I'm at home. And like, shut up, you guys. No, no, no. Well, these two guys, these two guys are sober. So they're not going to be going out with you, right?
他能不能，我们能不能去酒吧？他能不能，他能不能和大家社交？还是说直接回酒店，去蒸个桑拿？然后，他得去——不，斯科蒂，我在家呢。然后，你们闭嘴吧。不，不，不。这两个人，这两个人是戒酒的。所以他们不会跟你一起出去，对吧？
But we can drive. We can drive them. Yeah, maybe we'll drive you around. You can go get after it. Actually, Sean, it depends how much you're contributing during the live shows. You know, if it's as much as you've been contributing to the podcast, yeah, you'll be free to do whatever you want. Yeah, because you'll have plenty of energy.
不过我们可以开车。我们可以开车送他们。对，也许我们可以开车送你四处转转。你可以去尽情狂欢。说实话，肖恩，这取决于你在现场演出时的贡献有多大。你知道的，如果像你对播客的贡献那么大，对，你想干嘛就干嘛。是的，因为你会有充足的精力。
You don't have to answer to any. Thank you. By the way, Chelsea, thank you for managing expectations as we move forward. You know. What do you think? Chelsea, I do want to ask you,
你不用对任何人负责。谢谢。顺便说一句，切尔西，谢谢你在我们向前迈进的过程中帮我们管理预期。你知道的。你怎么看？切尔西，我确实想问你，
like, you've kind of had a bunch of different careers. Like, you're a stand-up and you're a stand-up. You didn't start as a stand-up, though. Is that right? I mean, you did it originally, but then you kind of became known also as you had your show, obviously, that was hugely successful,
就像，你其实经历过很多不同的职业。比如，你是个脱口秀演员，你确实是个脱口秀演员。不过你一开始不是演脱口秀的，对吧？我的意思是，你最初做过这个，但后来你也因为你的节目而出名，显然那个节目非常成功，
and now you've kind of come back to stand up and you've had this show on Netflix as well and you've gotten very political like you haven't had like a sort of a orthodox career not that anybody really does
而现在你又回到了脱口秀，你在Netflix上也有了这档节目，而且你变得非常关心政治，你没有走那种传统的职业路线，虽然也没谁真的会那样走
my point is where do you see yourself like what kind of shit do you want to do I don't know in the next five years or 10 years that you think's gonna interest you outside of just touring and shit do you see yourself like doing another show like a late night show or some shit you know
我的重点是，你觉得自己——除了巡演这些破事之外，你接下来五年或十年想搞点什么好玩的，你觉得会让你感兴趣的？你觉得自己会再做一档节目吗，比如深夜秀之类的，你知道的
I um yeah I did start out as a stand-up That's how I got my show So I did, just to clarify that I did start out, I did quit for a while When I burned myself out When I went over to Netflix to do my documentary series And I had like a three or four year contract with them
我，嗯，对，我确实是从脱口秀开始的，我就是靠那个得到了我的节目。所以我的确——澄清一下，我确实是从那开始的，我中间停了一段时间，当我把自己累垮的时候，当时我去Netflix做我的纪录片系列，我和他们签了大概三四年的合同
So I did all of that stuff I did my shows, I did a bunch of documentaries And I just sold my last book Which is life will be the death of me to a network To for me to star in I read that So it's kind of like a curve Sorry to interrupt how many
所以我就把那些都做了，我做了我的演出，做了一堆纪录片，而且我刚刚把我最后一本书《生活将是我覆灭的原因》（Life Will Be the Death of Me）卖给了一家电视台，由我来主演。我读过那个
How many books are you written? I know you've written a bunch. Six. Amazing. Amazing. That's pretty fucking impressive. Six number one New York Times bestsellers, guys. Is that true?
所以这有点像一个转折——抱歉打断一下，你写了多少本书？我知道你写过很多本。六本。太厉害了。太厉害了。这他妈相当让人印象深刻。六本纽约时报畅销书榜首，各位。是真的吗？
Six number ones? Yeah. That's incredible. That's really impressive. That's very impressive. Thanks. I know. Sometimes I can't believe it.
六本榜首？对。太不可思议了。真的让人印象深刻。非常让人印象深刻。谢谢。我知道。有时我自己都不敢相信。
That's awesome. So you're adapting that into a show? Yeah. So it's kind of like a curb your enthusiasm, like with me in therapy, just constantly fucking up, trying to decunt but never really being successful. I love that. It's another great title. Think about the, that.
太棒了。所以你要把它改编成节目？对。所以它有点像《抑制热情》（Curb Your Enthusiasm），就像我和我做心理治疗的场景，一直在疯狂搞砸，试图克制自己不去当个碧池，但从来没真正成功过。我喜欢这个。又是一个好名字。想想这个。
That is a title. You know, you just put like a weird symbol, phone symbol on there instead of the U and you're golden. Oh, yeah. Yeah. I wake up, I have to wake up two hours earlier than everyone, you guys, just to decont. I'm like, do not be a bitch today. You are one.
这真是一个好名字。你知道，你只要在那个词中间加一个奇怪的符号，比如电话符号，把中间的字母换掉，你就大功告成了。哦，耶。对。我醒来时，我得比你们所有人都早起两个小时，伙计们，就为了克制自己别当碧池。我心想：今天别当个混蛋。你本来就是。
Try not to be. Sure. Maybe spell it with a K and then a U with an umulat and then you might be able to get away with it. You're done. Yep. Good call. Yeah.
尽量别当。当然。也许用K开头的拼写，中间加个带变音符号的U，然后你可能就能蒙混过关了。你完了。没错。好主意。对。
I'll use the Kardashian font so that they'll think it's part of that. So when do you start doing that? Are you writing that now? script form? Yeah, Liz Tuchillo, who's the writer on it. She and I just sold it, so we're negotiating, you know, our deal. And yeah, we're on it. I'm pretty excited. I've never played myself on TV. I've never really done a television show where it was acting for, you know, so I feel like I'm in that mode right now. You know, late night talk shows. I mean, every time I say I'm not going to do something, I end up doing it, you know, so I don't want to say I'm never going to do that
我会用卡戴珊家族的字体，这样他们就会以为那是其中的一部分。那你们什么时候开始做那个？你现在在写剧本吗？对，写剧本。莉丝·图奇洛（Liz Tuchillo）是编剧。她和我刚把版权卖出去，所以我们正在谈合同什么的。对，我们在搞这个。我挺兴奋的。我从来没在电视上扮演过我自己。我以前从来没演过真正需要演技的电视剧，所以我觉得我目前正处于那种状态中。你知道，深夜脱口秀，我的意思是，每次我说我不打算做什么的时候，我最后总是会去做，所以我不希望说我再也不会去做那个
again, but I don't see myself interviewing. I like real people. Like, I'm on, My podcast, Dear Chelsea, people call in for advice, like it was supposed to be a joke and it kind of turned into something serious because I am that kind of person. I like people to take risks and I like to be a cheerleader and a big sister and be like, go, do that,
了，但我看不出自己去采访别人有什么意思。我喜欢真人。比如，在我的播客《亲爱的切尔西》（Dear Chelsea）里，人们打电话来寻求建议，这本来应该是个玩笑，但它不知怎么变成了一件严肃的事情，因为我就是那种人。我喜欢人们去冒险，我喜欢当个拉拉队队长和大姐姐，对他们说：去吧，去做那个，
break up with that guy, leave that job, you know? Stop talking to your mother. But so I just like that, I like talking to real people. I like interpersonal stories. And I've had my fair share of interviewing celebrities. And now that we have social media, it's not like there's any mystique laugh.
跟那个家伙分手，辞掉那份工作，懂吗？别再跟你妈说话了。但我就是喜欢这样，我喜欢和真人聊天。我喜欢人际关系的故事。我也经历过足够多的采访名人的日子了。而且现在我们有了社交媒体，大家身上或任何事情上已经没有什么神秘感可言了。
in anybody or anything. So that genre for me, or that medium, I should say, for me is no longer very exciting or challenging. You know, maybe something will happen to change that, but... What about acting? What about... Where does acting sit for you, playing somebody completely different?
所以对我和这种类型的节目——或者说这种媒介而言，它已经不再那么令人兴奋或具有挑战性了。你知道，也许会发生什么改变这种情况，但……演戏呢？演戏对你来说处于什么位置，去扮演一个完全不同的人？
Does that have any interest to you or is that sort of the antithesis of what you're interested in? If it were fun and it was a challenge, yeah. I mean, I do stuff... You know, I was going to do this Netflix movie where I played a principal of an elementary school that hated children, and I was like, oh, that's a fun role. Like, I could get off on that, you know?
这会对你有吸引力吗，还是说这恰好与你的兴趣相反？如果它很有趣而且是个挑战，会的。我的意思是，我会做一些……你知道，我本来要做一部Netflix的电影，我在里面饰演一个讨厌小孩子的、小学女校长，当时我想，哦，这是一个有趣的角。色，我能从中找到乐趣，你知道吗？
But then I couldn't do it with my tour in COVID. You have to come in and out of Vancouver. But I am always open to things like that. But, you know, it's not my jam. It's, you know, I don't consider myself an actress at all, but I love to have a nice challenge. Right, right. Yeah, right. I love that.
但后来由于我的巡演和疫情，我没法拍成。你得进出温哥华。但我对类似的事情总是持开放态度。不过，你知道，这不是我的菜。你知道的，我一点也不认为自己是个演员，但我喜欢接受一个不错的挑战。对，对。没错，对。我喜欢这个。
You know, who's acting I love, who I texted him about his acting is Jason. When I was watching Ozarks, I was, I was, first of all, I was on a panel with Laura Linney for a goop, a goop panel, where Gwyneth, and in New York City, this was like three or four years ago. And it was Laura Linney, Drew Barrymore, and a couple other girls. And they were talking about parenting. And, you know, we all had microphones in our hand.
你知道，我喜欢谁的演技，我还给他发过短信谈论他的演技，那就是杰森（Jason）。当我看着《黑钱胜地》（Ozarks）时，我——我，首先，我曾和劳拉·琳妮（Laura Linney）一起参加一个Goop座谈会，那是格温妮丝（Gwyneth）的Goop座谈会，在纽约市，大概是三四年前吧。当时有劳拉·琳妮、德鲁·巴里摩尔（Drew Barrymore）和另外几个女孩。她们在谈论育儿经。然后，你知道的，我们手里都拿着话筒。
And Laura Linney told the story about how difficult she, what a difficult time she had getting pregnant. And that she... They're going to say difficult time working with Jason. But yeah, keep going. Yeah, that too. She mentioned that too. and that was why she couldn't get pregnant was because of Jason is what she said.
劳拉·琳妮讲了一个故事，说她有多么艰难，她怀孕的过程是多么不容易，并且她……他们会说和杰森合作多艰难。不过，对，继续说。对，还有那个。她也提到了那个。
Did she say it was difficult to explaining what a Goop panel was to people in the street or no, that was easy? Yeah, yeah, she mentioned that too, yeah. But she talked about giving birth when she goes, you know, I struggled for so long and then I finally gave birth when I was 50 and I went into the microphone, like loudly.
她是不是说向街上的人解释什么是Goop座谈会很难，还是说那很简单？对，对，她也提到了那个，对。但她谈到生孩子时说，你知道的，我挣扎了那么久，然后终于在50岁时生下了孩子，而我对着话筒大声喊了出来。
And Laura Linney looked at me and I just went, congratulations, I'm sorry. I just, that is so disgusting to me. But, back to Laura and Jason on screen, I have to say, is one of my favorite shows on television because I just love watching Jason ads. I love it, love it. You nice lady, thank you.
劳拉·琳妮看着我，我直接来了一句：恭喜，我很抱歉。我只是——这让我觉得太倒胃口了。不过，回到屏幕上的劳拉和杰森，我必须说，这是我最喜欢的电视节目之一，因为我就是喜欢看杰森乱入。我太喜欢了，太喜欢了。你这个好心人，谢谢你。
He's very, very good, isn't he? We give him a lot of shit, but we love him. He's so good at what he does. Very charismatic, Jason, always. Very, very on screen, very charismatic on screen, very on screen. Definitely on screen. No, but in person, it's a surprising dud. It's pretty quiet.
他非常非常棒，对吧？我们虽然经常开他玩笑，但我们都很爱他。他在他做的事情上太出色了。杰森总是很有魅力。在银幕上非常有魅力，非常有银幕感，银幕表现力十足。绝对的银幕硬汉。不，但在现实中，他简直是个让人大跌眼镜的呆子。挺安静的。
But this is a lot of hate. Chelsea, thank you for your time. I know you're probably exhausted and this is the last thing you wanted to do today. But thanks for stopping by. You're hilarious. It was cool of you to say yes. You're such an original voice
但这招来了不少黑。切尔西，谢谢你抽出时间。我知道你可能已经筋疲力尽了，这绝对是你今天最不想做的事情。但谢谢你大驾光临。你太搞笑了。你能答应来真是太酷了。你是一个如此独具一格的声音
and where you think that you're at C-U-N-T, we think that you're hilarious and opinionated and awesome. So thank you. Thank you guys. So much fun to see you all. Thank you, Chelsea. Very much.
而且，虽然你觉得自己是个碧池（C-U-N-T），但我们觉得你搞笑、有主见又牛逼。所以谢谢你。谢谢你们。很高兴见到你们所有人。非常感谢，切尔西。
Great to see you. Have a great rest of the tour. Even you, Sean. Way to go, girl. Bye, Chelsea. Bye. Hello, friends. Yeah.
很高兴见到你。祝你接下来的巡演一切顺利。连你也算上，肖恩。干得漂亮，女孩。再见，切尔西。再见。大家好，朋友们。对。
Chelsea Handler, ladies and gentlemen. Yeah, so funny. Chelsea's so funny. Boy, she makes me laugh. I know, she makes me laugh too. She always does. Fearless. She's super funny.
女士们先生们，切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。对，太搞笑了。切尔西太搞笑了。天哪，她把我逗得哈哈大笑。我知道，她也把我逗笑。她总是这样。无所畏惧。她超级搞笑。
She wakes me up. She's very consistent. Always has lots of energy and ready to go. Even in casual conversation, you feel like, I got to be on my fucking toes because she will burn me. She'll correct me. She corrected you, Sean. She's corrected me before on stuff.
她能把我唤醒。她非常稳定。总是充满活力，随时准备开干。哪怕是在随意的谈话中，你也会觉得，我必须打起十二分精神，因为她会把我损得体无完肤。她会纠正我。她纠正过你，肖恩。她以前也纠正过我一些事。
She lives for it. Hey, man. I love it. If I wanted to be with my mom, I'd go back to Toronto. Like, why are you correcting me? But if you have any, if you have, if you like to, if you like to sling bullshit, you're in the wrong room with her. Yeah, I know. She's quick.
她活着就是为了这个。嘿，老兄。我太爱了。如果我想跟我妈在一起，我就会回多伦多去了。所以，你干嘛要纠正我？但如果你有什么——如果你喜欢，如果你喜欢胡说八道，那你跟她同处一室可就找错人了。对，我懂。她脑子转得极快。
Yeah, I do like that about her. It's pretty refreshing. You don't have to worry about talking about the weather because it's just, that's not going to cut it with her. Yeah. Yeah. I love it. A better show is great, too. Of course it is.
对，我挺喜欢她这一点的。这相当让人耳目一新。你不用担心去聊天气什么的，因为那招在她身上根本不管用。对。对。我太喜欢了。更好的节目也很棒，当然啦。
Oh, it's every incarnation of talk shows. She's so fucking funny. Yeah. And she does. I feel like she's. She says the thing that everybody wants to say, like Anne says it in a way, she's always surprising.
哦，脱口秀的各种形式她都玩过。她他妈太搞笑了。对。而且她确实。我觉得她是。她说出了所有人心里想说的话，安（Anne）也是用这种方式说出来的，她总是出人意料。
That's the thing it is. For me, it's always surprising what she says, like, catches me off guard, really funny, you know, really just, she says things so succinctly, much unlike what I'm doing right now. Yeah, nice job. Who's thinking of the buy right now? I am right now, but I think we need to start working on words
事情就是这样。对我来说，她说的总是让人意想不到，总能把我问得猝不及防，真的非常搞笑，你知道的，她言简意赅，这跟我现在做的事可太不一样了。对，干得漂亮。谁现在在想要怎么说“再见”？我正在想，但我觉得我们需要开始想一想
that rhyme with bye. Now, see, I was more interested in just connecting with you. you guys. I wasn't thinking about how to wrap it up. No, you know why I brought up? Because I could see the look on Sean's face. It looked like he'd been lobotomized. Well, he was writing. He's been writing for like 30 seconds, trying to figure out things that rhyme with his stuff. That's what he does.
跟“再见”（bye）押韵的词了。瞧，我当时更感兴趣的是跟你们交流。我才没去想怎么收尾呢。不，你知道我为什么提这个吗？因为我能看出肖恩脸上的表情。他看起来就像刚做过脑白质切除手术一样。好吧，他在写东西。他已经写了大概30秒了，在琢磨着跟他那些废话押韵的词。他就是这样。
You were talking, he was like this. And you're just trying to think of it. No, you guys. Almost like he's got like an overbite. No. No. I had both eyes, I had both eyes, open eyes. What? I don't think we're going to allow. Are you saying open eyes? Here's what's funny.
你在说话的时候，他就是这个表情。而你一直在绞尽脑汁地想。不，你们俩。看起来他有点地包天似的。不。不。我两只眼睛都睁着，我两只眼睛都睁得大大的。什么？我觉得我们不会允许。你是说睁大眼睛？搞笑的是这个。
Anytime I try to do it, I get shot down. And you always go real high. I don't know why. Why does it live high for you? I'll go down here. I don't know what the word you're saying is. And also, because you... Here comes, Will's going to try right now.
每当我想这么做时，我总会被打断。而且你总是把调子起得很高。我不知道为什么。为什么你总是起那么高？我降到这儿来。我不知道你刚才在说什么词。而且，因为你……威尔要开始尝试了。
I'm not trying. What I'm saying is, Sean, well, sometimes you'll try to shoehorn it in. Yeah. Right. You know what I mean? Yeah. And it just doesn't qualify.
我没在试。我的意思是，肖恩，有时候你会强行把它塞进去。对。你知道我的意思吗？对。而且它就是不合拍。
It doesn't qualify. Yeah, it just doesn't feel... We're going to sit here until we get one. I don't know, how did we back into this, by the way? Should we run the tapes back? When did this all start? Was it on the first episode? The very first one, yeah.
它就是不合拍。对，感觉就是不对……我们要一直坐在这儿，直到想出一个为止。我不知道，我们刚才怎么又扯到这上面来的，顺便问一下？要把带子倒回去放吗？这一切是从什么时候开始的？是第一期节目吗？绝对是第一期，对。
What did we just do a simple buy? Well, we could do it once a, yeah, we could do a simple buy, or we could just agree to do it once a year, or we could even do it bi-annually. No, we've used that one. Why? Have we used that already? We've used every single one.
刚才我们干嘛不直接说声简单的再见呢？好吧，我们可以每隔——对，我们可以说一声简单的再见，或者我们可以商量好一年说一次，甚至可以每半年说一次。不，那个我们用过了。为什么？那个我们已经用过了吗？我们把所有的都用遍了。
That's why I wonder if we should do rhymes or just say bye. How about we just, listener, we appreciate it, your time. Yeah, we do. Or will, why don't you give them, well, listener, we've taken up too much of your time. Shut up, Arnett. Why don't you get a fucking new goodbye line for our guests, by the way. Okay, I got notes for you. What do you talk?
这就是为什么我在想，我们到底是该整点押韵，还是就直接说再见。要不这样，听众朋友们，我们很感激你们抽出时间。对，我们确实很感激。或者威尔，要不你给他们——好吧，听众朋友们，我们占用了你们太多时间。闭嘴，阿奈特（Arnett）。顺便说一句，你为什么不给我们的嘉宾想个他妈的新的告别台词呢？好吧，我给你记下来了。你在说什——
When do I say that? When do I say that? We've taken too much of your time. Shut up. I don't say. How about it's an hour and we're done? Yeah, we're done. So thank you for your answers. Who do I say that to? You mean, I say that to the guest? I'm just as bad. I say, oh, gosh. No, you always say, oh my gosh, what do you got? Have you got something on the? How much did you pay them? Shut the fuck up?
我什么时候说过那个？我什么时候说过那个？我们占用了你们太多时间。闭嘴。我才没说。要不就说“时间到了，我们结束了”？对，我们结束了。所以谢谢你们的回答。这话我是对谁说的？你的意思是，这话我是对嘉宾说的？我也好不到哪去。我说，哦，天哪。不，你总是说，哦，天哪，你有什么？你有什么头绪吗？你给了他们多少钱？给老娘闭嘴？
Yeah, I know. All right. And you two chuckles. Yeah, Sean, we're coming for you next. Yeah, you're fucking next, Sean. Fuck both of you. How's that for low, not high? Holy shit, right?
对，我懂。好了。还有你们两个爱笑的家伙。对，肖恩，下一个就轮到你了。对，下一个就是你，他妈的肖恩。你们俩都滚蛋。刚才那种调子低而不高，感觉怎么样？太他妈绝了，对吧？
It's almost like he was about to bite our head off. Oh, my God. The fuck was that. Smart. smart less smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by michael grant terry rob armjarff and bennett barbago There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感觉他就像要扑上来咬我们一口似的。哦，天哪。那他妈到底是什么鬼。SmartLess是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）、罗布·阿姆贾夫（Rob Armjarff）和班尼特·巴尔巴戈（Bennett Barbago）100%有机纯手工制作的。本期节目还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。